i'm going to talk about the first early
sign of toxic kidneys all right so what
do the kidneys actually do
well they filter blood they are the main
blood filtering organs of the body you
have two of them and they filter roughly
about 1700 liters of blood every single
day and that's a lot of blood rushing
through these filters
the kidneys
remove waste and a big part of this
waste is the protein waste your body
doesn't store protein and so if you're
consuming excess protein that your body
doesn't need it's going to be releasing
the kidneys as waste your kidneys
actually get rid of excess minerals and
chemicals and it recycles a lot of
nutrients as well your kidneys control
blood pressure
they control your bone growth
the production of your red blood cells
so the kidney function goes way beyond
just filtering blood now before i get
into the early signs
i want to touch on one very important
point the most common reason for chronic
kidney disease and that is called
diabetic
nephropathy
now what do i mean nephropathy
nephropathy is a disease of your
nephrons and so the kidney is basically
made up of tiny little filters and those
are nephrons so a nephron is basically a
little filter composed of tiny little
capillaries and so you have all this
blood running through these kidneys to
little nephrons to the point where now
we're converting blood into urine and so
the common cause of this destruction
is high sugar flowing through your blood
sugar is very destructive to the
capillaries the blood flow that supplies
the nervous system
to the brain and also your fingers and
your toes and pretty much all the nerves
so if we did a deep dive and looked
through a very sophisticated microscope
of what's happening
this sugar is caramelizing
the tiny fibers of the blood vessels
and we're getting destruction of those
blood vessels and so we're going to get
leaking blood so if we look at the
kidney as kind of this vascular blood
vessel organ the high levels of sugar
create a leaking effect on the kidneys
so you're going to be leaking
things like protein and so too much
protein in the urine is an indicator of
kidney disease but what happens when you
lose protein
you're going to be deficient a protein
in your urine and then you start
disrupting the normal fluids in the
blood and you get edema so when the
protein the blood goes down you start
getting fluid that
leaks out into the tissues okay as a dna
so the number one early sign of kidney
damage
is
decreased urine output
because you're leaking fluid
in other places inside your body in your
ankles and your legs and your feet
around the eyes around the hands so
instead of eliminating the urine it's
kind of backing up into the tissues and
so when you urinate you're not going to
see
a large output of urine so that's the
number one symptom
but number two you're going to see
frequent urination now frequent
urination doesn't necessarily mean large
amount of urine coming out when you
urinate it just means that you're
urinating frequently smaller amounts on
top of a lot of retention of fluid
throughout the body so instead of that
fluid coming out of you it's kind of
backing up underneath the eyes on top of
the eyes uh in the ankles when you press
your finger into the ankle you'll leave
that little dent it's called pity edema
now some of you are saying wasn't that
the symptom of liver disease well just
think about this
well anytime you have
a kidney problem you're also going to
have a liver problem so there's no way
you're going to have a very sick liver
and a very very healthy kidney both the
kidney and the liver work very closely
together and so a lot of the symptoms
can cross over so number one decreased
urine output number two urinary
frequency number three ammonia smelling
urine
body odor
and breath now ammonia has a very
distinct
smell but that ammonia smell is
basically just more waste because the
kidneys are not able to do their job
when the kidney loses its function in
chronic kidney disease
you're losing up to 50 of those little
filters called nephrons so just think
about what happens to the toxicity in
your body and so sometimes people think
uh wow i'm deficient in protein in my
blood maybe i need to eat more protein
well that never helps all that's going
to do it's going to turn into more waste
and create more stress
on the kidneys number four your urine is
foamy that is an excessive byproduct of
protein it can also occur when you're
exercising intensely as well but if you
have foaming urine and you didn't just
exercise and you didn't just eat a lot
of protein
then
potentially it could be the kidney all
right number five you're cold all the
time okay
now one of the functions of the kidney
is to help
create red blood cells and if you're not
able to create red blood cells you
become anemic and you're cold all the
time
number six
itchy skin your skin can also be dry as
well as itchy so those two symptoms are
indicators that there could be a kidney
problem and number seven which occurs
with so many issues uh you're just going
to be tired all right so now that you
know the number one sign of early kidney
damage as well as some of the other
signs as well
what can you do about it now this is
this amazes me
when i've seen patients come in with
chronic kidney disease okay they're
going to the doctor some of them are on
kitty dialysis okay and they are given
no instruction
on what to eat what diet they should be
on they're given no instruction to
eliminate the massive amount of
carbohydrates that they're consuming i
know it's it's wild so of course number
one the most important thing especially
through diabetic it's just is to cut
down the carbs okay just cut them way
down as low as possible and get your
carbs from vegetables okay
not from grains because if you look at
chronic kidney disease
one of the recommendations would be you
know like whole grains cut back the red
meat cut back your salt why would anyone
want to add grains what benefits do
grains have on the kidneys
zero zero benefits and number two
you need to give up alcohol completely
um if you look at chronic kidney disease
they'll say reduce your alcohol now you
want to eliminate it why because you're
already in a very fragile state and the
kidney is damaged and just a little bit
of alcohol is just going to push you
further into the mud you're really not
at a place where you can afford to have
even just a little bit your diet has to
be very very clean if you want to
recover and the third point i want to
bring up is the amount of protein you
don't want to start doing no protein
you just want to do a moderate amount of
protein okay a high quality protein like
eggs or fish
or grass-fed you know meats things like
that as compared to protein powders or
some protein shake with soy protein
isolates you don't want to do that and
like i said get your carbs from your
vegetables have a lot of vegetables
moderate protein now i have some really
good additional information on what to
eat if your kidneys are not doing well i
put that up right here check it out